five big predictions for 2024 number one
Trump will be the GOP nominee my second
prediction is that there will be a
recession and the reason I'm predicting
this is not because I know anything
about the economy I don't the only
reason that I think that there will be
an economic recession is because Jim
Kramer on CNBC says there will not be a
recession my third prediction AI deep
fake porn is going to become a political
issue I think that women who are victim
of it whose faces and even bodies
perhaps are being put into this kind of
weird computerized porn thing I think
they're going to start suing in court
and I think that legislators are going
to take up the issue and pass laws
against it my fourth prediction Hunter
Biden will not face any serious
consequences for his crimes here's my
final prediction we for another year
once again will not find out who is on
Epstein's Client List